we approach them we only have two right
now so we have one that kind of makes
like our own custom controllers a little
bit and the other one kind of makes
gaming chairs but it's actually my
uncle's company so it was pretty easy at
them but the other one we actually had
to try to work for so yeah what would
you tell to me
if you talk to new people in terms of
building a channel
expectations well expectation is kind of
you have to have communication like you
have to know what you're doing a little
bit and a lot of patience yeah a lot of
patience that's the chair like getting a
lot of patience I don't really know many
of you guys have any tips or tricks
we'll try to check out the youtube
videos and see what they are doing and
maybe you can copy them a little bit
well not my goal is to work for mr. T's
is a gaming company
addicted to you
yeah I'm a huge fan of them and this is
one of their shirts refuse yeah we're
kind of just trying to like become like
not really like a solo youtuber but like
a company more and my tip is
a part of food
bad at collegedudes
unless you're doing a gig too
that how you
look if you're like just like quitting
all the time it looks funny or summer
but you're like yeah Marie guys you like
you're getting really mad and people
like you getting mad or something I can
also do like my videos of something that
you're very good at like basketball
baseball yeah pillow there's anything
you're good at is what you should kind
of go for like if you have a gear own
unique talent oh you're good at then go
and they make a video about that tower
pretty much
you